popping Rockstars it's me Mt and
Jonathan Majors recently confirmed that
King the Conqueror will be a Nexus being
like Scarlet Witch in the MCU but what
makes someone a Nexus being well Marvel
defines a Nexus being as a person with
enough power to drastically change the
fate of multiple universes or realities
and given this the list of Nexus beings
in the MCU that we've seen so far
include paying the Conqueror and he who
remains in all of their variants because
they have the energetic power to ravage
timelines with war discard the witch
when she learned how to dreamwalk with
the dark hold according to the
Illuminati every very end of Doctor
Strange especially Earth a38 Strange and
strange Supreme from what if then we
also have Ultron Infinity from what if
the universe eating dormammu from Doctor
Strange One the Multiverse defending
America Chavez The Watcher from what if
and of course finally Kevin from
She-Hulk who has the ultimate power in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe check out
my full video on the topic for more
information